[Music]
many winemakers these days are opting to
seal their bottles with technological
corks
these are Stoppers made of molded
particles of natural court which have
undergone a purification treatment to
remove the TCA molecule and other
contaminants which can give wine a musty
odor a specialized worker makes cuts in
the bark with an axe using a very
specific technique that doesn't harm the
tree using the handle of the axe he
gently prise off the bark a cork oak
typically lives for 300 years and can be
harvested up to 15 times grinds those
pieces into granules and then stores
them in huge bags the first step is to
empty the bags into silos that feed the
purification equipment the machines
which purify the quart granules are
giant autoclaves workers fill each one
with a ton of granules then they start
up the compressor which simultaneously
heats and pressurizes carbon dioxide
that then transforms into a semi liquid
gas called supercritical co2 which is an
environmentally friendly solvent they
inject the supercritical co2 into the
autoclave and wash the granules in it
for three hours the manufacturer mixes
it with a food-safe binding agent and
transfers the batch to the moulding line
the molding machine is
computer-controlled to automatically
adjust the moulds to the dimensions of
the stopper being produced the Machine
pours the cork mix into the molds which
then go into an oven for a few minutes
the ingredients bacon to a solid stopper
with just the right degree of elasticity
every stopper made in the same mold
shape is identical but no two Stoppers
cut from the whole pieces of cork are
ever the same because cork has natural
variations this is merely the corks
preliminary shape a computer-guided
machining center refines them to exactly
the shape ordered after finalizing the
dimensions the Machine chamfers one or
both ends a chamfer is a beveled edge
that makes it easier to insert the cork
into the bottle every cork then passes
in front of the camera which detects any
defects this machine conducts a
permeability test on a few samples from
each batch to measure how much oxygen
flows past the cork when it's in
position in the bottle the corks are
usually custom marked for a specific
winery